so I also want to start with a thank you
to thank for for inviting me it's been a
really interesting symposium so far I
look forward to more the same fact I
don't leave ever been to one that had a
title and a focus like this so it's kind
of a nice idea I think for a symposium
so I'll be talking about the work of a
single person in my lab Jonathan tang
he's a graduate student he's fantastic
he conceived of most of what I'm going
to tell you about and carried out most
of the experiments and I think that most
of you know that gfp is used to mark
cells or subcellular locations and that
there are now quite a collection of gfp
strains of mice from the genset project
or other strengths of animals for
example zebrafish has quite a few GFP
lines and what one can use them for is
is a multitude of things where one uses
microscopy to look at development or
morphology or count the number of cells
or even identify cells and this has been
an incredibly useful set of reagents for
people across many fields and we've
estimated that there's about 1500 GFP
lines now in mice again principally
driven by the genset project but there's
also many individuals who have created
GFP napkins or created transgenics using
a system regulatory region to drive GFP
and one ends up with these beautiful
collections of animals which have these
great marked cell types and again
they've been incredibly useful but we
were a little frustrated because we were
looking at all these beautiful patterns
and actually we wanted to do something
with the cells that were gfp labeled not
just look at them and jonathan thought
about this for quite a long time and
tried to figure out whether he could
actually use gfp then to study functions
of gfp-positive cells so his question
was could one actually use GFP the
molecule GFP to create biological
activities or regulate biological
activities only in gfp-positive cells so
we started reading about GFP and he
realized that probably the reason it's
been so useful as a marker is that it is
freely diffusal go throughout the cell
and it seems to have very little
interaction with cellular proteins it's
generally considered innocuous it's
fairly small fairly easy to manipulate
and that god I'm thinking about could we
use GFP again to manipulate activities
by endowment with some specific
activities or by using it to generate
activities and in his reading he came
across these very interesting antibodies
called camelid antibodies and probably
most of you know that a normal antibody
has four chains too heavy and too light
and the epitope binding domain is
created by 2 chainz coming together the
variable region of the heavy and the
light chain well camelids which are
Yama's alpacas camels and even some
cartilaginous fish like sharks have
evolved a way to make a two chain
antibody which also has a very high
affinity epitope binding region but very
fortuitously this region is made of only
one chain and it's a small domain so
these have been now exploited as high
affinity binding reagents called nano
bodies or chroma bodies that was done in
fact for gfp so a group at the
university or of the an in Munich Roth
Bauer and Leonhardt injected GFP into a
camelid and they raised high affinity
gfp binding domain antibodies of the
type I just showed you and then they
isolated the cdnas encoding the epitope
binding region that is a variable region
of the heavy chain and they showed for
example in this crystal structure that
the GBP gfp binding protein-1 in this
case was binding to a particular domain
of GFP they actually isolated seven of
these cdnas again they were all high
affinity they didn't map where the
others bound but one could imagine then
and Jonathan figured out that one could
take one of those cdnas and then fuse it
to other types of functional domains to
create a cdna that has now a gfp binding
portion and a functional domain and one
could then as say those to see if they
could Co occupy GFP so here's just the
idea of the assay is that one could then
by making these fusions and a saying for
Co occupancy if one could discover that
a pair of these gbps could Co occupy one
could make fusions so take the GBP fuse
to a particular functional domain
another GBP fused to a functional domain
and if they could co-op
pai-1 might be able to bring those two
domains together then an efficient
manner using GFP to create a novel
activity so these things would not come
together the hope was at any high rate
in the absence of GFP so we tested that
then by asking if we could constitute a
transcriptional regulation activity and
the idea was to take two different gbps
it could Co occupy fuse 12 a
transcription activation domain fuse the
other two a DNA binding domain and for
this test case he used the gal for DNA
binding domain which binds to UAS and a
used a vp-16 activation domain we also
supplied two cells as I'll show you a
UAS so can bind the DVD and a gene that
was easy to assay for most of the essays
I'll show you this is luciferase but we
can also use TD tomato for some of our
readouts and then put these elements
into a cell and see if in the presence
of GFP they could come together and then
turn on the gene of interest so we'll be
looking at assays where there's no gfp
or it's missing one of these components
and assays where all the components are
present in looking at luciferase for the
readout so this was first done in tissue
culture cells that HEK cells and this is
on the combination so you can see here
there's no GF p here's there's no
activation domain here no DNA binding
domain and here's all of the components
and when all of the components are
present we have quite a bit of Lisa
phrase readout but when any of them are
absent we lose it and you can see it's
quite a high induction rate he also
checks specificity he made a mutation in
the GBP one binding binding region and
that also did not work so it's very
specific to the normal gfp or some of
his clothes derivatives he looked at yfp
and cfp which are derived from gfp and
the system would also recognize those it
did not recognize the red fluorescent
proteins which it shouldn't these are
from a different organism so then the
fact that it worked led him to think
about other ways one could use it in
terms of having alternative DNA binding
domains alternative activation domains
and also perhaps ways to control the
timing of the onset so the GFP basically
gives the spatial
coordinates for the activation of a gene
but often GFP comes on at times or
places where you might not find it
convenient for your asset you might want
to turn on the GFP dependent activity
sometime after GFP comes on so he then
worked out a system which I'll show you
for drug inducibility and I won't show
you but he's also changed these
activation domains to get more or less
activity so he used the Tet system so
you many of you probably know there's
this element that recognizes a Ted
activator or Tet repressor and so by
changing the DNA binding domain to
recognize that Ted element he could then
get regulation by the addition of
doxycycline so doxycycline then will
activate this binding in this activity
and you can see here's a system with all
the components without docks I'm sorry
another components without dogs all the
components without docks and then we add
it we can titrate up the the readout of
the activity so this then gives one
temporal control and then this was all
done in tissue culture you wanted to
know if it worked in vivo so the way
that we test things in vivo is we use
electroporation to deliver plasmids to
the subretinal space of the developing
retina you've already heard about the
retina I won't be showing you too much
about it but I'll show you a few
sections of it but there's an incredibly
efficient electroporation method that we
can use where we can deliver at least
five plasmids at once into the same cell
so to test this that's what we did we
took a constitutive promoter driving gfp
the TD tomato now is the readout for the
activity the CAG DNA binding domain or
the CAG activation domain this is a
broadly active promoter driving the two
components and then this is an
electroporation marker lag Z so if we Co
electorate these in vivo into the
postnatal day 0 Mouse we can get
delivery into primarily progenitors the
plasmids are then passed off to the
neurons that are generated by those
progenitors and then we can a say
whether T DT comes on in a GFP dependent
manner a couple weeks later and we're
going to use the system to ask a couple
questions first of all is it dependent
upon GFP in vivo we're then going to ask
whether we affect neuronal physiology
with these components we were worried
because we're putting in a fair amount
of these activation domains we also want
to know if we could use G
p to turn on cree and then delete
endogenous floxed allele from the genome
and then also look at neuronal
physiology and gfp sales using out to
genetics so here's the experiment again
we take all these plasmids we put it
into a postnatal day 0 I and then we
look a couple weeks later it's sections
so if we look at the electroporation
control here we have beta gal readout
these are the cells that picked up the
DNA here as well in this particular set
of panels gfp was delivered so you see
all the cells that turned on gfp and now
you can see we're also getting the TD
tomato readout in other words this
worked we were able to turn on TD tomato
in the GFP positive cells if we left out
the GFP we got very little background
although jonathan is a very honest
person he told me I should show this
here's a little bit of background in
this particular case and if you're going
to use this your background probably
does depend on what kind of level you're
driving these components that this is
actually a pretty high level and we
don't get much background again we were
wondering if we might be altering
neurophysiology so we turned to some
collaborators at Harvard Bernardo
Sabatini's lab in particular genia cosas
robiskie and genia then electroporated
these components into the lateral
ventricle of an embryonic mouse and
ended up with the components being
expressed out here in a cortical area in
s1 she then made slices and she looked
for green cells as well as yellow cells
you can see those sections here so these
are cells that are expressing gfp and
this cells expressing TD tomato so this
means that this cell got all of these
components she then recorded from these
cells so she looked at non
electroporated cells cells had just had
gfp cells that had all the components
she injected current and she looked at
then the train of action potentials and
that's plotted down here she also looked
at membrane resistance and she also
looked at capacitance and they assure me
that these are very sensitive measures
of alterations in physiology and it
looks like we weren't perturbing in this
particular configuration anything that
she could measure we then went to know
if we could delete in a Dodge pneus
floxed gene so we delivered again in
vivo with electroporation to the retina
a gfp along with these components
and here we have creates a readout from
the UAS so we were hoping to have
creativity only in the GFP positive
cells and in this case we were using a
floxed allele of a gene otx2 that we
know is important in retinal development
so we knew what the readout should be in
terms of cell biology so here's just
some panels from those sections from
these mice so these are some cells that
got the GFP this is an antibody stain
for otx2 the gene we were removing and
you can see we lost the
immunohistochemical signal from the GFP
positive cells he then put in dsred and
for some reason he colored these green
it should be red but at any rate these
are cells that got dsred and we still
have the immunohistochemical signal for
otx2 and if we look at the readout in
terms of the cellular phenotype these
cells in the outer nuclear layer
shouldn't be here in a normal mouse so
this is evidence then that we've lost
the otx2 this is the known phenotype we
can find pac-6 positive cells here in
the outer nuclear layer when otx2 is
lost so this then means that you should
be able to delete endogenous floxed
alleles from an animal we also want to
know if we could help physiologist do
physiology from gfp-positive cells and
we as i mentioned we're interested in
the retina these are the bipolar cells
in the retina and there are two subtypes
of bipolar cells marked by a particular
GFP line called gustafson gfp the type 7
cone bipolars and the ride bipolars and
here's a picture of a of these cells in
the transgenic so Jonathan
electroporated in then the you a std
tomato along with these other components
and the cells that got electroporated
were indeed able to turn on TD tomato
and you can see there's very little
background and to the best of our
ability to assess this using morphology
these cells look perfectly normal so
then we wanted to know could
optogenetics be used to drive activity
in these electroporated gustafson
positive cells and for that we
collaborated with boat on Roscoe's lab
at the fmi in puzzle so the way that
boat on slab does experiments with the
retinas they take the retina out and
normally they shine light on the
photoreceptor layer and they record from
individual ganglion cells if you look at
a recording like that so this bar
indicates when
white is present on the retina and this
is the result of their recording so in a
normal configuration in a normal retina
the light is driving responses out of
these photoreceptor cells but we wanted
to know if we could drive responses out
of these gusts deuce and gfp cells so we
wanted to block the normal input from
the photoreceptor cells which can be
done by including a block or a PB and
when one does that one can quench the
responses from light emanating from the
photoreceptor cells so now electric
rating in the components along with a
UAS driving channelrhodopsin fuse to em
Jerry the expectation was that then
these gustafson positive gfp-positive
cells would be inducible with light to
hopefully drive activity in some of
these ganglion cells and that's what
they were able to show then with a shine
light in the presence of APB on this
configuration they could get responses
in these ganglion cells so this should
enable people to take the collection of
genset lines there's quite a few of them
that which mark subtypes not only a
bipolar cells but also of amacrine cells
and other cell types in the retina and
start to pick apart the different types
of activities oh I should also mention
they were able to fill the ganglion
cells after the recording so they could
then start to look at where the
dendrites are in other aspects of the
ganglion cell morphology Jonathan also
checked to see if this would work in
other species again where there are
transgenic GFP lines and we collaborated
with Matt Harris's lab at Children's
Hospital and they had a gfp line of
zebrafish you can see here and in this
case Jonathan injected the components
into the newly fertilized egg and he was
able to see the TD tomato read out in
the GFP strain but not in a strain that
doesn't have gfp and we have also a no
injection control here to look at again
activity or development to make sure
that we weren't creating some kind of
aberrant development so it looks like
this can work beyond just mice and
hopefully in other species where there
are transgenic gfp s so from this point
I'll just summarize what we've done with
what we call our tdawg's transcriptional
device is dependent on GFP I've shown
you that you can drive gene expression
using different activation domains and
binding sites and again that's in a gfp
dependent man
one can regulate the timing by using
doxycycline there's probably other types
of regulation that one can envision one
can use this then to basically turn a
GFP cell into a Kree cell and delete or
activate whatever one wants to do turn
on or turn off genes through pre
mediated excision and one can also do
physiology using optogenetics and it
works across species so we wanted to
know if this was more generalizable so
what we would have shown you here is all
transcription dependent activity we
wanted to know if we could also bring
together other protein domains to create
other types of activities dependent on
gfp and because again Cree is very
useful we thought we would explore
whether gfp itself could be brought
together so the configuration I just
showed you is driving Cree with a UAS so
this is a transcription configuration it
requires three components this fusion
protein this fusion protein and a UAS
Cree so we wanted to know if we could
simplify it a bit and also just see if
it was a little more generalizable by
taking Cree itself splitting it into two
and amino in a c-terminal half fusing
again to these gbps and then
reconstituting a Cree activity in the
presence of GFP you can imagine doing
this for example with protease Azure
signal transduction components something
that you might want to turn on only in
gfp dependent cells or positive cells so
again we used this assay where we're
looking at a luciferase read out in this
case what is going on is that Cree is
required to remove a stop cassette so
that luciferase can turn on and again we
do this first in tissue culture so this
is the activity in the presence of all
of the components and this is in the
absence of various components it doesn't
induce at quite as high level as the
transcriptional system but it still
gives a very nice boost it again is
dependent upon gfp and the gfp
derivatives it doesn't react with the or
doesn't it's not it enabled by the red
proteins and again we went in vivo using
electroporation so again this this mix
of plasmids but this time we have a
floxed dsred
as I read out and we're electro parading
and then we're looking here we're
introducing GF p with a constitutive
promoter so all of the electroporated
cells which are shown here in green you
can see almost all of them are turning
on the dsred for use instead a rod
specific promoter to drive gfp rhodopsin
gfp construct where we get nice
expression of gfp only in rods again we
get this nice specific kind of
activation there are cells that are
electroporated here you don't see any
turning on of the construct and if we
leave out GFP again we have a very nice
specificity here's the electroporation
control we had good electroporation but
we're not getting much background and
again I think background will depend for
different people perhaps on their system
but we've been really happy with the
level that we see here so now if you're
thinking of using these you might be
thinking about well how would you use
I'm not everybody is fortunate enough to
be able to electro / ate so many
plasmids into the cell type of interest
and electroporation in general doesn't
give you a fully transduced tissue so if
you want to use this to either get a
more full kind of coverage of your GF p
cells or you can't do electroporation
there are other ways to do that many
neuro scientists use a AV to deliver
their components of interest one can
obviously make transgenics and then
cross a gfp strain to a transgenic that
expresses these t dogs or Creed augs and
then include a UAS either again from an
aav or electroporation or another
transgenic construct so one can have
sort of a mix and match of transgenics
with electroporation a a DS etc
depending again on the on your needs and
finish they can actually deliver these
components using microinjection so we've
started to work then on a AV delivery
for these components and i'll show you
some data from our first set of AV
experiments so we made an aav that has a
generic fairly generic promoter that's
pretty useful the nervous system to
drive either gfp hopefully to activate
or another green fluorescent protein
from a different species which is not
should not be reactive and is not
reactive with the components so that's a
control we then have a
with either the n-terminal half of curry
or the c-terminal half of creases
secrete on configuration then we have
another AV that has a flux TD tomato so
if a cell is co-infected with all of
these things then they should become red
so it should be green and become red if
zs green is included they should be
green but not read its specific so again
we do this in vivo in the retina this is
now a cross section through the
horizontal cell layer which is the layer
just below the photoreceptors and you
can see that we have gfp very nicely
expressed here if we have an aav gfp or
zs green if we deliver zs green and we
have a very nice readout of the tomato
when we have gfp but not when we have
the zs green so now one can then turn on
basically any gene one puts into an aav
using the GFP again maybe the GFP is
from a transgenic maybe the GFP is from
an aav with a specific promoter or some
other kind of configuration but you can
then get the the t tomato to come on in
vivo this was pretty efficient in this
case I should say that a AV seems to
love horizontal cells so it's pretty
easy to get a high co-infection right
there so then we wanted to know if we
could use some transgenic gfp lines that
one might want to study the function of
so again we took these AAVS that have
one of them has the n-terminal one has a
c-terminal the gfp is now coming from a
transgenic and we were looking for a
readout of TD tomato only in the GFP
positive cells so this is a subset of
ganglion cells you're looking at the
inside surface of the retina this is a
transgenic line we're only a subset
there's lots and lots of ganglion cells
here just a subset as being marked in
this particular gfp strain we infected
with those components and we look for
the TD tomato readout and you can see
that we're getting nice TD tomato
readout these are blood vessels which
caused us some background with this
channel and if you look to see if those
are gfp specific almost all of them are
so here's just a few of them you can see
that they are co-localized them with the
gfp so if one can then access subsets of
cells in the nervous system with these
AAVS what can one do with that so one of
the things that we're interested in an
hour
that's interested in as some of the
circuits that are in the retina you've
heard a little bit about that already
this is the lineup of ganglion cells
this is a Makran cells these are bipolar
cells I already mentioned those these
are the horizontals these are the
photoreceptors and we really don't know
the circuits among all these different
cell types but we know that different
ganglion cells are connected to
different kinds of amacrine cells or
bipolars so it would be nice to start to
look at individual subsets of ganglion
cells and ask for example if this
ganglion cell is GF p plus who are
synaptic partners among the a Micron's
or the bipolars so we can now use the
components to do that we can combine
this with some viral tracing so our
lives been developing vsv and other labs
are using rabies virus or pseudo rabies
virus to as transcend optic tracers to
look at synaptically connected cells so
here's just a cartoon explaining how one
could combine these methods so here's a
cross-sectional sort of cartoon very
simplified of the retina again there's
many kinds of a microns and galleons but
if you have a subset of gfp-positive
ganglion cells you can start to ask
again about their upstream partners and
one can do that by combining the GFP
components these these t-dog or creed
ogg's with viral tracing so some of you
are very familiar with this this is how
it's been used for monosynaptic tracing
with rabies i'll just described I'll
walk you through it if you're not
familiar with it so if you had a GF p
subset of ganglion cells one could use
the t dogs or creed ogg's to have those
cells and only those cells express a
viral receptor called TVA and again one
can do that by AV infection with the t
dogs with an aav that has a UAS driving
TVA so one cohen jax these things only
the gfp cells should express the
receptor one could also inject for
example the AAVS with t dogs and use a
floxed strain of mice we made a flux TV
a strain is available Jackson labs so
one can again have just just the GFP
cells expressing TVA one can then
introduce a viral construct and this can
be done by intravitreal injection for
example and if that virus is equipped
with an NVA glycoprotein it can only
infect the TVA cells so by adjusting the
dose of the virus or at this
the dose of the av's one can again get a
random sampling of the GFP cells
infected then with that virus now if one
also includes a soap one in fact sorry
let's say that virus has a cherry
reporter when will now have the TVA
cells or some subset of those TVA cells
expressing the virus and if one wants to
then look at the upstream connections
that is the amacrine cells one can also
include a viral g protein which enables
retrograde transmission of that virus
and let's say that virus is crippled
such that it can only spread from a cell
in which you supply that viral g protein
that means you can then start to look at
the partners because the virus will only
be able to transmit from those cells
that get the tdawg components the uas g
etc so one can target these cells using
the TVA and then one can direct the
virus retrograde by virtue of also
delivering the g protein in a GFP
dependent manner one can change the g
protein so that the virus can also go
anterograde and there's at least a dozen
retino recipient areas in the brain so
one can start to look upstream and
downstream from a GFP set of neurons
using these components so just get a
little bit of summary here then if you
have gfp lines that you're interested in
using you can deliver components either
by electroporation microinjection viral
delivery you can mate also two
transgenic mice we have we're in the
process of making transgenics where the
Cree components the amino and c-terminal
Cree dog components are being knocked
into a constitutively expressed locust
we're also going to make some UAS
versions we're also going to make some
of the t-dog ones but hopefully the
first ones to come out will be the Cree
because many people are interested in
Cree and I should mention that some
neuro scientists want more specificity
than one can get with just a single line
of transgenics Susan to mickey's lab has
developed a very nice intersectional
method where they have a readout in her
case they've been using for example the
dread receptors and the dread receptors
are equipped with both FRT and loxp
sites so that the only cells that will
turn on the dread receptor are those
that get criando mating mice
have different expression patterns for
Cree and flip one gets an intersection
and that intersection then are the cells
that turn on the dread well there's not
that many flip lines many of you
probably know there's very few flip
lines although there's a lot of gfp
lines and there are fewer but still
quite a few cree lines so one could take
a gfp line and use a UAS flip so
essentially create flip lines out of gfp
lines and made them to creel ines and
then have the intersection between gfp
and cree give the intersection for
alleles which are both Korean flip
dependent so I think that will also be a
very nice use of this and again expanse
or the use of all of the GFP and Cree
lines that exist right now just so just
to summarize I've shown you that you can
use gfp to create gain and loss of
function scenarios one can go beyond
even just create recombinase in terms of
sorry Cree recombination of a floxed
allele that's in the genome one can also
deliver for example hair pins that are
flexed you can also do some circuitry
mapping I hope that this will be useful
to people who are losing rabies or vsv
or pseudo rabies virus in combination
than with the GFP transgenics out the
genetics is a possibility and as I
mentioned one can use the GFP to create
a flip to then lead to the
intersectional possibilities and I think
this is more perhaps could be more broad
in terms of concept or application that
one can think about using even non-model
organisms where one doesn't have gfp but
if one wants to make these camelid
antibodies for an intracellular antigen
and i'll just throw out a possibility
some intracellular antigen like a GAD
protein perhaps that might be specific
to a subset of cells that you want to
study then you can use again this whole
approach of getting the binding proteins
that are high affinity then making the
fusion proteins etc to then target
specific cell types and animals that we
don't have transgenics for so that's
possible and really you can think about
other types of molecular switches
there's a lot of clever biologists out
there and I'm sure that you can think of
other ways that one can use gfp or
another protein to scaffold together two
or three activities and
again novel activities there's quite a
few you know animals in which you can at
least introduce components even if you
can't do it in the really broad way
that's been done for the mouse or the
zebrafish but at least one has the
possibility to introduce components and
just to again acknowledge the people who
have done is we were very fortunate that
leonhardt and Roth Bauer gave us those
gbps the start of our studies the
cortical slice physiology was done in
Bernardo Sabatini's lab we had great
collaborators in Baton roscas lab to do
the retinal physiology and the zebrafish
work was done with Matt Harris's lab so
I'll stop there and glad to take
questions so you mean in a gfp
transgenic where we don't actually see
the gfp do we get reporter activity yes
we have seen that in fact this these
components are a little more sensitive
than gfp itself so we know it's not
background because we don't see it in
gfp negative strains so if you have a
strain where you know maybe with
antibody and really pushing it you see a
little gfp you will probably see these
readouts in those cells now I can say
that you can dumb it down if you want by
delivering less of the components yep
yes we've been thinking about that and
using an MS two or something to then
create I think that's a reasonable
possibility and that would be very nice
in terms of gainst picking up cell type
specificity and and really being able to
do I think some combinatorial things so
I just follow up with a a glorious
question I think sometimes it possible
when the GOP is like a broken down so
the antibody still can recognize the
fragments but we don't see f-4s in
protein they're my them I explain your
background you should
yeah so again I want to say it's not
background because we don't see in GOP
negative sales but yes I think the
sensitivity of different assays are
different and I think that one just has
to you know think about how one is a
saying things to know what you're really
looking at so um I'm here so I have like
a flip side of the question how's the
penetrance like is like every
gfp-positive cells that would be
accounted for the Cree expression or the
subsequent zone yeah so I think it again
depends on the delivery method so we can
get over ninety percent with the
electroporation of cells that we
calculate get all the components so when
we electroporated on't get every single
cell getting all five components but we
can actually make a correction for that
and of all the cells they get all five
components it's over ninety percent show
us the readout but I think again this is
really going to depend on how you
deliver the components and the
expression level of the components we
haven't been able to look yet in
transgenic configuration that'll be
interesting to see when we know every
cell has the components that will be a
nice way to look and also to see maybe
gfp dosage dependence I didn't I took
that slide out but there I should say
about gfp dosage dependence it's
interesting there's really high levels
of gfp you start to lose the reporter
which is actually predicted based on the
way it works because you can titrate out
so each GBP has its own GF b so one gfp
doesn't bring together two components if
there's a lot of gfp we sort of saturate
all the GBP so really high levels you
start to lose it but in a practical
sense we actually haven't lost there's
very few strains or situations where I
think that will pertain and it is
interesting also on the low end it's
actually quite sensitive again cells
that don't appear gfp-positive can still
have the readout yeah so that now that
is my real cushion so in the way
actually I was thinking about your at
the end of your talk you're talking
about using some endogenous component to
to use this technology in some way
actually think it's better to use
exogenous components because the if you
use the endogenous component you might
titrate out
the component also you might sort of
might hurt to sell to yeah I might move
the extras like a settles plasma protein
into the nucleus almost hope you want to
yeah I think the idea of using and
dodges would have to be you have to be
really careful considering what you want
to use because i think it and this also
is pertinent for the question about RNA
i think that if you are going to bind up
a cellular component that might be
useful to the cell that you don't want
to probably bind it all of it up and you
probably don't want to drag it into
different compartments either so i think
the ideal would be something that's
expressed at a fairly high level and
then not expressing a really high level
of the component so again you're not
saturating out all of that cellular
component I think we'll just have to
it's probably going to be idiosyncratic
you know a case-by-case but I think for
people who don't have any other options
and non-model organisms it might be
something that they would want to
consider